Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast. Ooh,
Hyundai April 9th,
2012.
Um, and uh, we're gonna do some,
a little different this week rather
than me just sitting here in my pajamas
ranting,
ranting and raving.
I decided that I would get closed this
week and have a friend of mine come by.
The one and only dom. I rera
everybody. Thank you everybody.
Do you mind if I get undressed?
Huh? I would feel more comfortable.
I like in the nude, in
the news, in the nude,
in the nude. You know, I think
it's very fitting that I'm,
I'm with a Daigo bastard. Like Ewan was
sitting here drinking the Vino. Hey,
not for nothing. You mic brick, but let
me tell you something that is funny.
Is it that I bring red wine over with
a little class little you're doing.
I was embarrassed that I only had a one,
a red wine glass and the fact that
the only thing I've had here is stuff.
Stuff I brought over. And you had a
delicious Sushi dinner. I've done. Okay.
Let me tell delicious.
I thought I thought I told Don to come
here at seven 30 so me and Nia ordered
some Sushi and evidently I said seven
and this guy's Johnny on the spot.
Seven o'clock, right? As a
structures in the professional.
I didn't think I delivered it, didn't
I? I know. And then you showed up.
The only thing I could offer you is
the fucking wine that you brought.
Do you want some the at a mommy
with your one and you said to me,
well listen, let's quit fucking around
here. All right, let's get serious comedy.
No. Yeah, let's sit down. I want to know
about your process when you sit down, Tom,
when we're going to talk about comedy
here, talking to about my instrument,
tune my instrument.
We're going to talk about two comedians
were going to sit here for an hour and
talk about the logistics. Is that the
right word? You can use that word.
When you put the pen to the paper.
Did you see the, you get a little heavy
now bill, but you see the masters today?
I did. And, uh, were you happy
that Bubba Bubba Watson won it?
You know,
I like seeing different people with
it's thing that's amazing to me is the
nerves it takes when you know, a friend
of mine is a scratch Golfer, he goes,
the one guy goes, why don't you
turn pro? Because you have no idea.
The difference between me being
alone out on a course, you know,
hitting his 70 when the compared to
millions of people looking at you. Yeah.
You know what always blows
my mind at those, those,
those PGA things is when those guys go
to tee off and they hit it like 300 miles
an hour.
All those people standing gen off to
the right and the left sitting there in
their face just like
they've really trust them.
They're looking for a subway
to come. Yeah. Yeah. Like what?
Bobby's shot there when he was,
he was in the pine needles.
I mean everyone was staying there.
There was a guy sitting
there was like a camera,
like the level of faith that they had.
The one guy did get hit today.
Did you know? I saw him getting it
yesterday. I saw a guy get hit you.
That's how we do it. It was, it was
like a delayed reaction. This old guy,
he hit her head.
I didn't get hit like center mass.
You couldn't see cause those people but
as low enough where it wasn't his head
and it looked like he was walking
around looking for the ball and all of a
sudden they just sort of collapse this
tree and then the announcer just goes,
oh dear one. Damn. Somebody
got hurt and just whispered it.
W I wonder what happened if somebody
got killed like I got hit in the temple.
You think they'd stopped the match
after they took the ambulance?
Took the body away?
No,
I think that they would keep going and
not say that he was dead. It would ruin.
It doesn't look good. It would
ruin spectate. The spectator,
the spectator part of it.
We then have to all be wearing helmets
and stuff like that. Years later.
People Goggles. Yeah. Years later
people would watch it on youtube.
The way you watch like a goalie back
in the day that didn't wear a mask.
This guy's out of his fucking not,
I'm still there on the fairway.
And you play golf. No I don't. I, I,
I appreciate the game but I,
I'm just be in a no pigment Irishman.
I mean by the fourth hole.
I don't give a fuck. It sounds great.
You go out there with your friends,
you get a 12 pack and
you, you know, you just,
we could make a lot of money cause they
had like these celebrity things that you
could go on and they, you've got an
offer as a golf with people, right.
Maybe carrying somebody bags, how many
you got and those kinds of things. I mean,
celebrity golf,
now I'm out of that loop.
Well I'd have to go out
there with some big,
like Hannibal Lecter Sun hat that he
wore it like at the end of the morning.
But they had, if they had nighttime
golfing, golfing, I would do it.
I have friends at golf a lot.
I just don't want to suck at something
else at this age. You know what I mean?
So I stick to, I stick on the
close to the vest. I shoot pool,
I played ping pong because I love
ending up where I started. [inaudible]
there was no big thing.
People go,
you play ping pong like what are you
a hand for the fe with the people.
My thing is I don't play like standing
there with a beer in my hand. I play like,
you know, you put some spin on it. I put
some spin on mother. You don't, you don't,
you know who you got to. You got to play
as a Jimmy Dore. Was he good? Jimmy Dore,
Jimmy Dore invites you over, you know
the whole area is Jimmy Dore brings you,
invite you. If you think you just
go on over there to uh, you know,
have some burgers.
It has lovely place and really he's,
he's just sick of beating everybody
in his neighborhood and he talks shit,
where's he at?
And like silver lake or something.
I don't want to out where he's at.
He's like,
this is about as far as I'll
go and only because I love you.
This is as far as it's come and these
fucking God damn fucking Moss. You know,
you're old when you have
to buy a a cedar chest,
take chest of drawers because they're
eating at your old man sweaters.
I wear the V neck sweaters now on stage.
I go with that with a t shirt
underneath the casual look. Yeah.
I'm trying to disguise how much I,
I dropped the F bomb on my act.
I figure if I dress, how many, how
need to have a February 15 minutes.
Why usually do four days when I go out.
So I got four different colors.
Maybe I'll switch it up with a button
down just to the wait staff doesn't start
snickering at me.
Off the record.
I always show you were sharp Joseph
off the record. I'll take that.
And even that Maroon goes, go with
your eyes. Well, you know, I mean,
I knew you were coming over
Tom. I appreciate that.
Appreciate the look. Listen,
that fucking guy today who
won that thing. Okay. I'm, I'm
sitting there, uh, the, the,
the fucking, uh, golf
thing. I'm, why I watch
it every year. I think
it's awesome, right.
But I'm looking at the guy and I'm texting
back and forth. My Buddy Paul Versey,
um,
back east and when,
when he hit it off that that pine
needle, that was amazing. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Insane. And
went right to, you know,
landed right there and then he
tube goes in two putts and wins it.
He said that that was the equivalent to
when Eli through that pass to Manningham.
And I was just like, dude,
you know, oh this year,
don't compare like real sports to golf.
So Golf was delicious.
Like a giant pool table. Yeah, it's
a, it's a three hour mind. Fuck,
I will give you that.
But it's just like Eli had a 300 pound
guy in his face taking, you know,
taking a shot to the head. It's,
it's not, this is what kills me.
This is what the thing about golf,
first of all did,
you saw it bubbling when he won and
he's got, I think that double chin,
this seventh grader arms,
he never took a lesson in his life.
And Tiger Woods is on the course.
And so Phil Mickelson,
so that's like Gretzky and fucking,
uh,
Mario Lemieux are out there
and he beat him. So it's like,
I know guys who suck at
sports like really bad.
Like you throwing the ball and they
like tense up. It's one guy I know,
like when he goes to shoot hoop, it's
the fucking, it's like the greatest,
like if physical comedy ever seen,
he bites his bottom lip and he holds the
ball right in front of his face so he
can't even see the rim. And at the
last second, he bends both as risks.
So we can see it for half a second and
then throws a line drive and it hits the
underpart of the rim. That's how bad
this guy, he gets on a golf course,
he can compete,
he can hit it straight.
And I'm saying he kills guys
and wins money out there,
but to watch him hit a golf ball,
you'd have no idea.
They give you like going
to play softball here.
Let's see you hit a golf ball high.
Let's, let's get this guy out there.
This guy's struck out.
I worked with him.
He struck out slow pitch softball
with a girl. Underhanded.
Struck out to the point. He
was so embarrassed. I remember
later on that night, uh,
this is how long ago was
he got me wine coolers.
It was the 80 as discussed the hell.
They were horrible.
But you a psych if you underage.
He was like, uh, and I was like,
this sounds like getting molested story,
but I swear to God it was.
I had to go back and I threw him
pitches until it was dark out.
I think it was the next night.
The next night I did it.
He was so fucking embarrassed.
He struck out three times and
everyone was giving him shit at work.
But this guy can go to the golf course.
So I, I think bowling, Golf Pool,
I know people have said this before, but
after watching that guy went today, I, I,
you know, I totally
respect the game. I think,
oh shit. One of the things about golf
is you can also be a normal person.
And I mean like in basketball you
can't be normal. You're how many?
Six 10 guys did you see today? You know?
Yeah. When you go to the mall, how many?
Six 10 guys,
you'll see none because it's so,
it's such a freak game and the guys that
are small or even freaks cause their
quickness is being unbelief.
Like John Stockton,
his hands were twice as big as ours.
There's always something freaky
about something. It's spelling. Yeah,
but in golf you can be like pretty
much a normal guy for some reason.
You got that, you whack
that ball, whatever
it is, the Torque, the physics
behind it. All golfers,
they're all like almost in shape. Right?
But I mean the guy, a little bit of packs,
but they got little bit of a belly. Dude,
if you can kill that fucking mouth, man.
I meant killing them every God damn
week. Oh Shit. How did you miss that?
I didn't miss it. I hit it. I
do. I stunned them all rang.
He looked at me, just see him looking
at me. How much of a Dick I am, I,
I got you over here. You brought the
wine. He got an offer. You might have
now eaten that my clothing and I'm
giving you shit about it and I was always
good to you, Bill. I took care
of you in back in the day.
Now early on you were really mean to me.
Get the fuck out. You used to bully me.
Yeah, right, you did? Yeah. When I was
in the comedy locker room and you came in
way back in the day,
that was just horseplay and we
had some horseplay is horseplay.
Well nowadays is considered hazing.
You know I have a friend who's
prosecuting that Sandusky case. Oh yeah.
He went off the other day. He
went to television. You went off
on that sand. Duskin his lawyer. But
by the way, not to be egotistical.
This is pretty funny about ask his lawyer.
I said,
what an idiot that guy is because
I see such a more like it.
And they go and my friend Joe goes,
I gotta tell you something dumb.
He's a big fan of yours. If they
said, what an idiot, well, he's that,
I'm not finished. There's so bad.
He does have good taste. The comedy,
how many times? That's a, that's
a great thing to bring up though.
How many times have you made
fun of somebody in your act?
They like a cartoon deal and then
all of a sudden, you know, five,
six years later you're standing
in the room with them. Oh
yeah. And then you just,
then you're just going, oh my
God. Did they hear what I said?
Well, one of my first jokes, uh,
that was a closer joke in my act
was before I did the tonight show.
I did star search right now when you
did the tonight show was Atlanta or no,
it was Carson Carson. So, but I did the
stage here, but before I did is I show,
after I'd done star search,
I had a joke about it McMahon.
The joke was a kind of went, like
I said, I meet Ed Mcmahon. I said,
I'm thrilled 35 years in the business.
What do I say to them in a calm ed?
Do I call him Mister Ed? They'll call him
mister e. Mr Eddie Mcmahon, Mr Ubic, fat,
lucky talentless Hump Kissing
Johnny's ass for the last 30 years.
You Budweiser's sucked in outposts,
slinging nothing. What do you do?
I don't mean that in a bad way,
but that was the joke. And uh,
he comes up to me right before I go on
to say hi to me. No, I didn't know that.
He thought the joke was
funny that he had seen me.
They knew who I was and he pulls me
towards it. I'm thinking, Oh shit,
ed McMahon is gonna slide guy
real big six floor, you know,
and he was strong then.
This was what this was like before
he got kind of Strunk and, and older.
And I thought, man, I that make
man's going to sucker, man.
I got to go on stun my first
tonight. Chose that, you know,
but I'm starting to be
saying, well, what he's,
what are you gonna just said he'd
have a great set and you know,
he was just very nice, you know, but
he had, he heard the better and he had,
but I didn't know he had,
his daughter told me he had,
and then we worked together at the
Philadelphia Academy of Music doing some
benefit. And he told me he loved the
bit, you know, he thought it was funny.
Let's see.
Yeah, we gotta love a guy who was
like comfortable with a, yeah,
with where he's at. He's big enough that
you, that he's famous and it's funny.
So in that sense, so you don't do
jokes about, not to talk about comedy,
but how fucking nerve wracking was it to
do the tonight show with Johnny Carson?
Because there was that whole thing that
you couldn't just go out and have a good
snow. He had to get the
okay. The thumbs. Okay.
Was like you did good thumbs up.
It was the imprimatur of comedy.
I mean it was like,
you know,
most of the time you got called over
either because he wanted you over there or
because of timing.
And you know that guy who's that comedian,
that really alcohol comedian from
Boston. Teddy bears on. Yeah.
And no offense to teddy, but he got it.
Got It. I get it. I can open my hand.
I can't open my hand cause I got it.
We'll just keep squeezing your hand.
Was He there? He got fucking crawl
away again. Sorry. I tell you,
he's indestructible. He looked at me
like, you got to bring to the table. Yeah,
it gets a bit more to
the table and that baby,
but a teddy apparently did too long,
so they brought him over to the thing,
you know.
But what we were asking me before,
it was an interesting thing
because there was no fun in it.
There was no joy in it. All it was
was a passing, passing through some,
some worm tunnel.
It was like the White Apollo in a way,
but rather than the crowd,
it was like he was going to pull
you by just not bringing you over.
And I remember looking out into
the hills and Burbank thinking,
I'm going to run away.
I'll start a new life up in the woods.
I really did because I couldn't. It was
so, there was no fun. My fucking head was,
he led the curse. Yeah. My
head was pounding my, my I,
I never get headaches.
I would buy a pounding headache.
My heart was beaten like a rabbit's,
you know? And then I got off,
he gave me the songs,
they told me we got to have you back.
And that was like how many like hours
of just absolute relief is that?
Oh, that must have just been
unreal. Yeah, that's what I always,
I hope the amount of times I
think that like why do I do this?
As you're standing there before
you're going out like kids,
I'm really actually a really introverted
person before I started doing this shit.
So now I'm just sort of a loud mouth
asshole kind of grew into, but you know,
just from being on stage.
But like the first I would say like eight,
nine years of doing this shit I,
the amount of times I was just standing
in the waiting to go on in some fucking
impossible situ with some awful, yeah,
like next third show or something.
We were around for those days and all
the Nick's, Nick's comedy South Boston,
I started at nick. That was a,
I mean luckily the, the guys,
the Boston comics were good to me, but
that was a tough place. I was brutal.
That was tough. If you are from
Boston, I heard show Friday. Yeah.
And then they would put like
10 fucking Boston headliners.
But see they took care of me, you
know like uh, Gavin and Sweeney,
they all looked out for me and he,
they didn't try and bury me, whatever,
for whatever reason we always got
along. So it was different for me. Like,
like I heard Richard Lewis was so
upset because somebody's swinging,
he goes follow right. Follow that.
All my stuff, my esoteric stuff,
Boston stuff.
And Richard apparently hid under the
seats hit under the stage until everybody
left. Yeah. I don't know
why they used to do that,
but they, I guess they used
to get territorial or it's
really kind of a funny,
funny thing considering I didn't have to
go through it and I wasn't from out of
town. The fact that they'd be like, you
know, what do you need a headline is for,
we're here,
we can close this and that you would
cause so many comics do when you go on the
road, tried to bury you, but they never
have the audacity of just say like,
follow that. You know, they always watched
my back. They were always good to me,
but does your, then you ended up stealing
from the club and what happened there?
I stole from the club. Yeah.
You don't remember that cash.
The guy went out. And
what do you know? Uh,
does your audience know that you were
the one I was part of the, I'm sorry.
That's all right.
We got to do a commercial here anyways.
Hang on one second and get a fucking type
in this stupid password. Um, all right,
here we go. stamps.com everybody. Dom,
I don't know if you've heard about this,
but do you hate going to the post office?
I hate it. I absolutely can't stand it.
Why do you have a suggestion?
Oh, wouldn't it be great, Donna?
If somehow you could have the post
office within your own apartment. Great.
It'd be more, it'd be
unbelievable. Unbelievable.
But if you know somebody that
could do then these guys,
stamps.com you can print out, what's his
name? stamps.com. It's, it's a standard.
It's a stamps.com.
stamps.com stamps.com I'm
actually using this product.
If printout stamps, they give you a
scale said to shell. I send out my,
this is the excitement. The hype. Oh they,
they give you a scale stamps.com yeah
you can weigh your packages and maybe the
lady is saying, you know, have a
little little bit more play with it.
You can weigh him in your house.
Yes you can Wainwright and yet you put,
you put it on a little visor. Dude. It's
awesome. It sounds like a great idea.
It is awesome because every time, every
time I go down there there's always some,
you know, I can't say the way
I can't curse during these ads.
I got in trouble last week cause I
dropped the c note that'll go to the post
office because I have a business manager
and all but you know at your level I
guess you still,
oh you want that behind the music
stuff where they steal all your money.
That's good. Did you sign away your
power of attorney stamps.com everybody,
if you,
if you act now and use my last name bird,
you can get a no risk trial plus $110
bonus offer that includes a free scale and
$55 of free postage. Too serious. I
swear to God. Let's go. Wait, Tom,
go to stamps.com before you do anything
else before I can't finish the show,
I can't.
I gotta go out.
I have to do is click the microphone on
the top of the homepage and you type in
my last name, Burb, B u r.
R for this special offer for my
listeners and sick and tired.
I get a flat free.
They give me fresh microphones for every
shot he killed that moth scale dead.
You get a scale.
Tell me what you get again,
just like a scale to weigh the packages,
you get $55 in of free postage.
Wow.
It's actually, it's a hell of a
deal. This is a very good deal. Yeah,
and people are responding to
stamps.com it's a hell of a deal.
That should be in their bumper sticker,
stamps.com. It's a hell of a deal.
All right, back to the podcast here. Um,
now does your audience know
that you were the one that, uh,
I mean I was the one that kind of sparked,
sparked but kind of set you up a little
and then when he did that brilliant rant
and Camden, oh, the Philly thing, Bill. Oh
yeah, you went, you went on before. Yeah.
You went out. You were one of the other
ones who went to the, uh, and you also,
they started booing you
and you didn't leave,
but for some reason they
didn't put that on Youtube. No,
I told them that I make $12,000
in 10 minutes. Fuck. You know,
I remember you standing there going like,
why,
why would you think you
guys could make me leave?
And they actually paused from
booing you for half a second,
but it was only the people in the back of,
the thing I loved about you was you were
like sticking up for me and I thought
that was really cool. And you
went, they boot dom Irrera like,
like one of my heroes. Fuck, come on.
You remember when I was in Boston and
somebody new you a headliner and was
saying that a yeah.
You know,
the other night don was in town and
we were shooting pool and I remember
thinking that that was smart.
He knows dom I rarer,
so I was psyched to be working
with you and not to mention,
do you remember that line up that night?
Yeah,
the way that they would be because
everyone went out there and there was that
dance motherfucker vibe. Do
the, as far as I can remember,
it was rich Vos. Tracy Morgan.
Yeah. Remember Tracy Tree?
So Neil, you, Bobby Kelly, me,
Jimmy Schubert, Jimmy Schubert.
They booed me. Schubert. They
didn't let him say a word. He says,
I bombed and see you can't
bond with a late at talk.
You can't bomb when it's still light
and you're standing outside and half the
crowd is sitting down. That poor
bastard brought half his family there.
But the funniest guy, I know
Jim Norton. Ralphie may,
that was the show.
Dude.
I can tell you in 20 years people are
going to look back at that lineup and be
like, why were people getting booed?
They were drinking all day. It was crazy.
And it just outside though. Can I tell
you something? My car, my deserve it.
Cause like in 1988 I went to go see
a dice clay at the Worcester Centrum,
uh, at the height of that, uh,
of the dice stuff and an unknown
Eddie Griffin was opening for him,
which is a great time for comedy and we
will all Boone and out when I was born
it was who? Eddie Griffin. Yeah.
Eddie. It was your born Eddie Griffin.
He wasn't famous.
I wasn't a comic and I was doing
that more on audience sing like that.
Tyson is going to love us because we're
doing this because we want dice to come
on. And, and Eddie Griffin stood
there going, fuck you mother fuckers.
I'm not getting off stage. And
people kind of like, Whoa, oh,
we thought you were just going to run off.
And then he ended up killing doing that
Michael Jackson thing that he did or
something killed.
He ended up turning around and killed.
So that's the thing about that Philly
thing. Why don't make such a big deal?
Because I was like, guys, a
bunch of guys have done that.
There just was no youtube where you told
me that they expect you to do it after
that. But I gotta tell you the
funniest line for some reason.
Fuck the Liberty Bell. I Dunno
why, but that made me cry.
I lash and like what the fuck?
The Liberty Bell Dunne.
I'm with nab.
I hope he gets an HDL to shift flyers.
Have a once is Gerald Ford was president,
but then fuck the liberty.
That's like so many Boston yelling at
somebody going, hey, fuck Paul revere.
Like we give a shit. Right, right. Damn
man. I'm saying don't talk about our bell.
Hey, don't talk about our
tourist attractions like that.
That's not the boat's buddy.
Yeah.
And that was, uh, one of a,
now they're happy night on that happened
on the happy night on the road when you
got anything. And I, rumor
has it that you're going to
be starting up your own, uh,
your own podcast.
And rumor has it that I might be on a
short list of guests that you're trying.
Well,
yeah,
you said that you didn't want to do it
right away because we're talking now,
but I want you to do it as
soon as you want to do it.
It's going to be a dom Irrera
live at the laugh factory.
I'll come, I'll come down
and do it, Mike. Mike,
because you're our conversational guy.
I just don't like when I go and I do
somebody's podcast and for an hour we tell
all our stories to each other,
blah, blah blah. And then hey,
come and do my podcast next week.
And then I had always feels like what
I did for VH one where I wasn't on,
I love the eighties I was on,
I love the 80 strikes back.
So they had already talked
about all the a level shit.
So when I came through it was like,
do you remember,
what would you do for a Klondike Bar?
All the Eddie Murphy Raw,
uh, back to the future. All that shit
was gone and it was like the really, uh,
do you remember a show called square
pegs? A, you know, Short live show?
Can you got to comedy on that? It was
really like a, so that, that, that's,
that would be the reason why I
don't do that though. But if you,
if you're wondering,
I want to tell you,
I really appreciate you breaking
out your new shoes for this.
These aren't new.
I just don't wear them much because
they look like bowling shoes.
These are Todd's there. I was
going to say bowling shoes. He 85
a shoe. Three 85 a shoe.
That's how expensive
you have to be.
Can't buy a pair by him individually.
I bought,
I bought the first one and then the
other one I'm going to come back and get
later. How do you rate bill?
What's your process? Well,
you know what it is is I try and
go out and live a life. Okay.
And then it writes itself.
And as a community you always
have to be observing things.
You know the newspaper I read like 17
newspapers a day. Dot. That's what I do.
Wow. I just cause I want
to see it from every angle.
So you're more of a informative person
than an actual comedian, do you?
You don't even go for lab.
Oh No, no, no, not at all. Well, you've
seen my sets down there, don't. Yeah.
Well what dumb. That's what I always
loved about watching you on stage.
I didn't go for left handed to the
crab Felicity to just stand there,
stare at me and just not walk off stage.
It was this amazing.
I want that crowd think,
and this is what I'm more of a
motivational speaker when they,
when they leave my show, I want them
to think, fuck, I could do that.
So that's what I'm about you with the
labs and the killing I, yeah, it's old.
It's old school. I liked the teaching.
You know what I love what comedians say.
A true story like that makes a difference.
Like,
like they're going to leave say savor.
Yeah, that was a true story. Yeah.
But you're going out at the end
that go, you know, a second guy.
I didn't think he was funny,
but when you talk about
my God, he was honest. I think there
was other guys made that shit up.
That really funny shit. Oh well, you
know what I love is you, you, uh,
you still come down and work
out and I always work out.
I feel like there's just a handful of
us who once you start selling tickets on
the roads will still go down. I don't
know why guys who take off to the club,
I mean, I understand that like if you're
married and like I'm single right now,
but even when I wasn't, my girlfriend
didn't understand. I go, well,
I'm trying to get better, but what
do you think? I said, you know,
like you can't say like, like when I
did the tonight show, that was 1987.
Right. That's a long time
ago that, you know, I could,
I mean I PR you have to practice. I can't
let go. Like, if you play basketball,
you can't say to somebody, uh, you know,
I usually score 25 points of the
game and he's going to, well,
you know what palliate you
scored for tonight. So, you
know, I, you want to be good.
I mean, I know you have the same
motivation that I have to keep improving.
You're not, you're not really
competing against anybody else.
You just compete with yourself.
I am competing with a lot of people.
Who are you jealous of? Who's
really makes you angry? Success.
It's just something about,
you know what it is.
I've always been jealous like swagger.
My tough guy to know about you is your,
uh, your, your arm wrestling abilities.
Mm. We were talking about that last
night. Not to be a name dropper. What?
Renee Zellweger cute. You ever
see her live beautiful? No,
I've only seen it in the movies with that.
That fucking guy looks like Phil
Mickelson buddies from England.
You got to go to the
hooker. Oh yeah, yeah. Yes.
It should've been like on the $20,000.
Yeah.
The one that he was that hookers
name like names like Phillip North.
What the fuck was his name now? I
forgot I'm Harry Harrington. No,
it's something Bobby Bittman. Yeah,
it was like, oh, he's Rosenthal.
It was like something, just a
little Rosenthal. He's the producer.
Draymond now he's a, what the fuck
was his name? Harry crumb. No, no,
I don't. I'm terrible at names.
Harry. You really terrible.
It's not able to close your gray
Harry Carey Harrington. Hugh grant.
I knew that. Something like that. What
was the hunter's Dan Remembers? Uh,
it would be a great memory. That'd be
a great recall. It's like destiny or
holy shit get good that she has to ask
me. What a question though. She was hot.
She was hot, she was hot. And she,
she, you know, and that's, you know,
that's one of those great things
about being a hooker here in la.
Just like everybody at any moment.
You don't know.
You're gonna run into lot of exposure
and movie star. It was great exposure.
How about the Eddie Murphy
thing with the transvestite?
Was that ever proven though? Well, he,
I think, I think it was proven that he,
you know,
and nobody could ever prove that he didn't
know it was that he knew it was a man.
But,
uh,
you don't go to Santa Monica Boulevard
and pick up a regular hookers.
What if you're going just going to
swing it by yum, yum donuts. He,
this happened to me. They
look, I don't think Eddie
Murphy, he's a brilliant actor,
but I mean the thing is the
way, what is with all the, what,
what's the deal with all deal?
What's the deal with all the doughnut
places out these people and why
do they eat so many doughnuts?
I don't have a Billy donuts.
Never seen so many, not only so many
fucking doughnut shops out here,
but they're all like,
seem to be independently owned and uh,
everyone has a different
name is yum, yum donuts. Go,
go down another Arlo boy, they got some
donuts and everybody out here works out.
Who pays the whole you to a
hole in the middle of the year,
your friend Renee Zellweger eat a dozen
and then fucking Yak. I'm up in Maya.
What I was going to say, but at any
point when you were talking to her,
did she do some sort of touching of your
arm or maybe tapped you on me and it
just made you feel like
a little boy again? Well,
she had to believe that
Chris was like her. Her whole
aura aura is really positive.
Entered her.
She is right in the middle of her chest.
She is a centrally located key.
But uh, but you know how
I met her. Listen to this,
talk about a name dropping thing first
was on a Sunday night. I'm in Cleveland.
It's snowing sideways. It was so bad
at next day. Fox, it was snowing.
I'm telling you it was start
talking about Snowden. I'll tow.
It's got ran off the lake. It's a
lake effect. Snow. It's real snow.
It's like effect. You see the
difference. Uh, but uh, I'm,
I'm sitting in Cleveland
looking out the window of the,
I'm not even going to
get out of here tomorrow.
I had to go to a reading
ready for this name drop city.
Sean Penn had called me up the
Jesus Christ dom. I know. Wait,
there's more to read with
the Chazz Palminteri Deniro.
Renee Zellweger go fuck yourself for what?
For a movie.
A comedy movie about,
and I was supposed to play deniros
brother now shorts over Broadway. Yeah.
Bullets of row. No, this is really, this
is just last year. The matter of fact,
they called me a month ago to come
in and read the rewrites with them,
but I couldn't make it. I
have bronchitis. But uh,
I'm sitting there and I've really turned
into woody Allen because at the end of
the thing, I, you know,
I just got to kind of a crush on Renee
Zellweger and she's so pretty and soak
such a good actress and she says,
you really good to cause I hope I get to
work with you babe. And she said, Babe.
And I went and I was walking down the
steps alone. I'm going, she called me be
Babe Babe. Yeah. Powerful. The
power of a beautiful and figure,
but if they have famous, yeah, I did a,
I did a show one time and down Irvine
down at the mall there and a the end of
the show there's this woman came up and
just really quickly shook my hand and,
and then said really funny and then left.
I'm telling you,
it was like fucking electricity
was in our hand and it was,
it was the chick from the white snake
videos who walked around in the of the
white dress still looking good. But
like, and I had no idea who she was,
but she just had like that.
Like there was no way she wasn't going
to become famous. I'm telling you dude,
she shook my hand and it was like fucking
a lightning bolt. Went through it.
There's definitely energy and she's like,
I don't know,
pushing 50 and there was all these other
20 something year old hotties and I'm
watching her out the door. Like, who the
fuck was that? Well, he doesn't
want to talk like that. Oh,
that you had that sort of electricity dom.
Do you ever wish that you had that sort
of, I never went. You know, he wish I did.
Even when I was good looking,
I wasn't a good look at the it factor.
You know what? I love that. Who,
who's been uh, um, uh, oh man,
I can't forget his name died. Passed away
was when my favorite character, Jenny,
no. Uh, the pharmacy fields,
the to April, April, go to Abbott
and Costello. Ah, they used to,
he was a former teacher and he used to
do that. Welcome back Kotter. Nope. Nope.
He passed away. Fuck man. It's now
it's becoming really stressful.
The show redhead,
redhead with the mustache does Wartburg
Dennis Wolfsburg when he used to do they
just say that cause I'm bad with
names and then I totally love the guy.
Then I panicked and then I just forget
it. This is why I do this. I sucked.
You're blocking, you're blocking.
I'm putting too much pressure.
That's why I don't golf.
I don't golf with these bubbles.
He's self taught guys who beat the
Gretzky's in the Mario Muse. Um,
he used to do this bit about the
it factor, having it with women.
But remember that joke you can,
I don't know what it is.
I don't think I ever had it.
He goes, but whatever it is,
I have the antidote gentlemen.
And he would stick his tongue out.
Fucking love Doug Guy. I probably
just butchered his God damn joke.
And it was probably gonna say there's
a funny, but you know, he was, he was,
he mugged a lot, but he was
funny. Oh, it's just to me,
this whole act was mugging.
He went, he went out to, uh, the
comedy connection of Providence,
right in the end when he
was sick and he sat down,
I heard about Lloyd and
got a standing ovation.
I heard he did that and they already
did Boston when it was still open to
connection. Absolutely
destroyed you. I heard one time,
I heard you one time,
you did a set half sitting,
half standing simultaneously either
in your fucking destroyed it.
No cracks me up is like a c
like better the kid, you know,
what does he like 39, good shape,
whatever. He started looking guy. Yeah,
and he sits down after
about two minutes on stage.
We don't 15 minutes to
calm store all day long.
We all fuck who don't work and then he
sits down. He takes a break. Two minutes.
Oh boy.
Anybody fired and he looks like he could
do like 40 pull ups when he wakes up.
He could do it. I'm sure he could. Yeah.
Well I'm glad we finally got to that
about 40 minutes. Then we finally know,
30 minutes said that we realized that
a bright orange says he's really one of
the, one of the more lazier guys out
here, which is, yeah, he's a lazy,
funny comedian.
This is the kind of things,
I mean I can't believe you got me to
admit certain things in the show or you're
about to to. I want to make
your cry is what I want to do.
I think since somehow
Brent Ernst's killing while
sitting down and being better
looking and in better
shape than both of us,
I think this is going to
lead you to crank. Well, I
realize now, you know, look,
look how much weight I've
gained right now. You know,
I've gained since I've known
you for 30 pounds. All right?
And I know that I can't tell.
Well, you don't really look,
you don't really check me out. It is all
done. Look at my head. My head is bigger.
What are you wearing?
That slimming black tee
shirt.
I've got a Bob Barry bonds head,
but it's interesting because now, and
I don't even know if this is a bit yet,
Bill, but I think there's
something in it. I have to look.
I don't like women my own age,
and you know what I mean? I can't,
I can't fake that. I could get aroused
by them. No, I always wanted it.
I wish I had that kind of
love or something, but I
need like a hot young chick.
But the only hot young chick I'm
going to get has to be floored.
She's gotta be daddy issue
inside or outside. Yeah.
He's gotta be messed up in some way.
But that's what I'm looking for.
How many, uh, how many strippers
have you, have you dated,
dated, uh, only a couple. I was
in love with Warren. How old?
How old were you when you did, when
you made that move? Uh, two years ago.
You fell in love with the
stretch? Yeah. When you,
first of all this a
country song, she was, um,
she was not stripping at the time.
She was bartending and just
given the occasional lap dance
and really beautiful girl and under
that bar and fun. But I'll tell you,
oxycontin and alcohol really mess you up.
I don't know if you knew that,
but I still loved the girl,
but she's a, I don't think,
I don't think we're getting
back together that oxy,
her husband and their two
kids keep blocking us.
Oh, Jesus. Dom, you're making
me feel good. Make me feel good.
Some of the choices I made
back in the day, dude, oxy
is, uh, that's a terrible one,
right? Yeah. That's one of those things
like even when you get off at your,
I don't know that you're ever, uh,
depending on how long you do it, the same.
I lost a buddy of mine did that. I got
another one. He's not doing so well.
Did you grow up in a neighborhood that
was a lot of drugs. I'm not like that.
Not like that. It was a, I
grew up, you know, it was, it
was called the sac bullshit.
It was weed.
There was the weed guy,
there was the bookie and then w and then
there was, you know blues obviously,
but you know in some coke
when you got older, but uh,
like nobody was doing like
heroin and crack was like,
you're out of your fucking mind. Cause
everybody thought if you smoke crack,
that was it. You had done well the, they
say you get addicted the first time.
The look, that's what they said. But I,
I got friends of mine who had did
and they're like, yeah, you're okay.
It was all right. Still Rolling. Yeah.
Maybe they're addicted to other things.
They don't have time to be. Maybe they're
just better people. Better, stronger.
You have good friends.
Let me ask you this.
If you had one drug that you think
you would like, what would it be?
I know what mine is. If you, if I could
do a drug that I've never tried it,
we tried and you think that like it's
not going to have any repercussions.
Just want to the feeling.
What feeling would it be?
I have a tie. Well, I want to know.
I want to know what it feels like.
Like that train spotting where you
sink into the rug the first time you do
heroin. That's exactly, that's
exactly what I want that.
But I got to admit the hallucinating
thing tripping. Yeah, but I'll,
but that doesn't go on your trip it,
and it's not like you don't know
the a trepan you the door fucking
melting. You're like, oh,
it's because I'm on acid.
It's not like those high school
films where you'd be like,
you thought you could fly in.
That jumped out to me.
Uh, what was that movie with that
old guy? Was it something to me,
Larry Allen Ark and did a part where he
played an old guy and he fucking, uh,
he just, he got addicted to heroin
like his seventies and he's just like,
what the fuck? I'm 70. That's a guy
she had good idea just to try it at 70.
I mean I'd rather go out shooting drugs
and go out taking a kick in the ass.
That must hurt man. That's a
thing. You ever think about
that seriously bill? Yeah.
Excepting one at things. Take one for
the team and taking one for the team.
I dime your number came up. So you're
not going to like this like this.
I don't think so. We worked this out. Now
I've actually thought of early a priest.
How I,
how I want to go out in by wolves.
Eat shredded by animals.
Yeah.
I either want to live to be like 105 like
you lived so long that there's nobody
at your funeral because you outlived
everyone who gives a shit or you know,
cause that,
that is funny image cause that's one
of the things if you live long enough,
I'm sure we had people that cared
about people doing the eulogy. Like,
I mean ever since I met him when he
was 87 and uh, you know, he was old,
like he like playing cards,
which were those slippers.
He always wore those slippers.
But if you die,
like you know,
like all my friends,
you know who have died tragically
fucking young it seems,
I mean you pack the house and
everybody's up there try and get a good,
that's the only good thing about dying
young is everybody gives a fuck it,
there's articles written about you.
There's nothing worse when,
I mean there's nothing worse than dying
yet, but Diane old also is, you know,
you sit in there that you've got
that fucking old terrified picture.
My uncle Tony, when he died, he really
was very prejudiced and very angry,
but he also loved his children.
He loved God, he loved mountains.
And then when he died was so fun.
Is that makeup for the racist side yet?
But I'm saying he was that balance process
on people in the nature love Berlin.
It's true though.
He was like all that and he's,
and we're standing around the coffin.
You see that mountain. It's for us.
That's for us. Not these other
people. This is God's country.
But when we're around the
quote from we're standing,
you know people lie about people after
they died and this guy leaves the Deli,
who was the first a tank character ever
did? Like I got down a little, he said,
we're staying there.
Me and a friend of mine who a priest and
like a couple of my cousins and we're
standing there, oh over
the body. And he goes,
he never had a bad word
to say about anybody.
And we went from crying to fucking
laugh. I'm thinking, I said,
all they do is have bare word said,
but everybody, and then he goes,
listen to this, this is a
really old reference. He goes,
he never hated anybody except Larry Bowa.
Right.
Larry both of the old for the Phillies
and he, and he looks up, he goes, he
hated that motherfucker would engine. Huh?
Was he a gambler? No, he didn't gamble.
He just hated him.
He hated the Larry Boat cause he hit
one 75 but he was a great fielder.
But I mean, Halloween. What a, what an
obscure reference to make at a funeral.
And so in general,
back in the day,
he probably just didn't like
second basement frustrating,
maybe that the floor.
But I love that everybody laughed.
I've had a couple of those it like
funerals were crying, crying, crying,
the crying,
laughing.
I did that one time a buddy of mine,
his dad died and it was just one of those
fucking, you know, tragic. You know,
we were young and he died on a
nowhere and the kid had already lost,
his mom was fucking horrible.
And uh, so it was pouring,
raining to make it even worse. Fucking
like the, remember the movie seven?
It was raining like that. Okay.
Yeah. So we, we, you know,
go, you know, go through the surface
and now they're going to, you know,
put the guy in the ground and
the guy was so popular. I mean,
it was just a zillion people there. So
they had like one of these, you know,
one of those pop tents with no sides to
it. So there's so many fucking people,
everybody's jamming in there. Me
and my buddy can't get in. You know,
we're on the outer ring,
we're just getting rained on and shit.
And my other asshole friend is just
inside the tent and he's sitting there and
we're all crying and stuff and it bringing
the body down and all of a sudden,
just from the weight of the rain,
like this little like canal started
pouring down in just missing my friend and
my buddy in the middle of
crimes was standing range,
just reached up and adjusted it.
So it went all over as a coach.
But he had like this wool kind of coat
on so he couldn't feel it at first.
And Dude, I'm talking, crying, laughing,
just crying because it
was so sad and that,
that's the thing too that I never thought
people ever understand about comics
when they have a distasteful joke,
like a boat sinks as a plane
crash and you have a job.
They always think it's cause you're
insensitive and they'd sometimes don't
understand that it's, it's a defense
mechanism where exciting. The pain. Yeah,
I'm feeling something bad. I don't
want to feel it. And then you, you,
you make a fucking joke and then you're
laughing because you don't want to feel
that. So you actually doing it because you
can, it's kind of a, I think, I think, uh,
a dysfunction.
It's kind of a form of dysfunction.
Well, like the pedophile jokes,
we all know how terrible that is.
And yet you could twist sentences, but
you could, you could twist it around.
I usually bring it back on myself.
You know, like a one jokes that says,
you know what about me, father, I wasn't
hot enough for you. You know what I mean?
Like that kind of thing to make it me.
I wouldn't want to hurt a kid.
But there is a good example of something
that has caused so many people,
so much pain. And I'm not just talking
about the physical pain, but um, you know,
we do,
you're, you end somebody's life when
you, that's why that that sent Dusky guy.
Yeah. You know, like they
shouldn't put those get date.
They should automatically get the
death penalty just immediately.
They take 'em out. Dude, if you've
got a rabid dog in your neighborhood,
you fucking put it down. Those
sex offender guys, that's it.
Because all those people
that that dude fucked with,
it's like that's can now affect,
you want to talk about dating strippers?
Like how that's going
to affect who they pick.
You know who they pick as a
uh, a wife, how they treat
their kids. They might, they,
there's a chance that they
could, you know, sometimes,
I don't know if he had happened,
I'm going to go beyond my intelligence
on this shit, which isn't too hard to do,
but I all I know is that
that's generations of therapy
because of the abuse of
the, they, they repeat the whoever.
Yeah. Those guys, they don't get the,
you can't put that guy in jail and like,
I mean,
how long like you're attracted to what
you're attracted to or in a cell. Well,
especially with, at Dartmouth,
they stuck you in a cell.
How long before you wouldn't
like big tented strippers,
you'd come out 80 years
later. I'm dumb. I,
I get bring me to some
big tatted stripper. Those
guys, like eight year olds,
you stick them in a cell
and you talked to him.
You try to undo it and show him an adult
that they're wired that way. That's it.
Just fucking sick. Is that put in,
put them to add. It's terrific.
It's why I don't believe in a
higher power that gives a fuck.
Well that's a whole different subject,
but I understand that.
But do you hear that pedophile joke about,
uh, he might have a total joke joke. No,
not at all.
It's a two guys sitting on a bench.
You see an 11 year old boy walked by, one
guy better. Paul says to the other one,
it goes, boy, he must have
been hot back in [inaudible].
He must've been subbed
the back in the day.
Oh, that's fucking twisted here. And
with that, a little more advertising.
Oh yeah.
But that's still,
I still like to stamp the Isaiah
Dotcom was tremendous for me. Bill I,
amazon.com. Oh, okay. I got think now
telling me about it. Oh Geez. Dom,
I would love to, I'm so glad you said
that. I was worried that you would say,
hey bill, don't tell me about that.
Cause I hear great things about Amazon.
I don't know enough.
Oh
this is the deal.
I'm not saying you have to buy something,
but the next time you buy something on
amazon.com if you want to contribute to
the podcast,
go to [inaudible] dot com click on
podcast and on the right hand side,
under the guy tunes window,
you'll see the little banner for Amazon.
If you click on that, you know by whatever
you want to buy a pen and pencil set,
go buy some used truck. I don't care.
Whatever you do, just go through, uh,
my website,
click on the amazon.com and then they'll
know people are listening to you and
supporting Amazon.
so@amazon.com amazon.com actually does
is they kicked me a little bit of money
and then I take 10% of that to give it
to the wounded warriors project so you
can uh, contributing to my, everybody,
everybody, everybody wins and you get,
you get something in the
mail like it's Christmas.
That's one of the great things
about ordering something
offline because a lot of
times you forgot, you ordered it and
you had a bad day and you come home.
There's like a little, it's like
a present. Let's nice. You know,
and you forget that your body.
No.
I heard great things about that
company and I've worked there.
I was talking to a friend of
mine from Cleveland, by the way,
I'm playing hilarides this week in
Cleveland. Oh, let's hype it. Wow. Yeah.
What days? Thursday, Friday,
Saturday, Sunday. Only
four days only. Dude, how great
is net cost? This is great. Yeah.
The nervous nervous
Nelly of on one of my fit
and can still knock out a 20 year
old at whatever. What does he like?
65 Oh, at least it's still still, I was
given a break there. He's still like, oh,
I didn't mean it. I mean he's
in curls and all of that. Yeah.
Last time I was there as
motorcycles to allegedly,
allegedly someone who looked like him,
a yank somebody out of a car and a,
yeah, tune them up a little bit. As
they say back east. Really? Yeah.
The guy kept blowing his horn,
you know, you know? Yeah.
Nixon that gets worked out.
Yeah. Nick's no joke. And
this thing about him too,
he's a truly as a tough
guy because he didn't tell,
he didn't tell me he did it.
Somebody else did.
You know somebody who doesn't fight.
So he, Oh, I grabbed this guy,
nick didn't say shit.
Somebody else told me the story
that was laughing my ass off.
And I went and said, hey, you know, I
heard some guy was beeping the horn at,
you know what happened?
Cause I wanted to hear the story for him.
And the way he told the story
was, oh that's right. No,
he told me the story first.
I said, hey, you know, how's
business going? And he tells
me the story like I ain't,
it's been cool. You know how he
kind of had a problem with this guy?
You know the guy, you
know, he kinda, you know,
I just had to kind of sort some stuff out
or whatever. Just the way he told him.
I said, there'll be great in a
movie like him, some real tough guy.
Tell him the story and then you smash
cut to like what's really going went down
and his head against the
quiet. No, like, yeah.
Like he seemed like he went
into one of those rages way.
You don't even remember what you did.
I wanted to work things out with them,
you know? Yeah. Greatest guy ever. And
I absolutely love that club. And uh,
I'm hoping, I'm trying to work on a
date there right now, but dom Irrera,
the legendary, the one and only the
guy with the swagger swagger swagger,
who's who has table reads
with Renee Zellweger,
she calls him sweetie is a jealous
Robert Deniro, stairs bullets at you.
He was damn near broke character,
right. He starts laughing,
which I thought was great.
The one of the greatest American actors,
and I say to this guy who
wrote the script and go,
it was so fun for me to see Robert
Dinero getting the giggles and breaking
character. He goes, well, you know, he
doesn't really put everything into that.
And I said, Oh, you don't have to defend
Robert than hero to me. Well, you know,
I was in Puss in boots in
children's theater. He's,
he's doing raging bull and I'm
going to put some boots, you know,
it's great actor. I can't, it's just a
table read. It's like, you know, I like,
I liked it.
He said that to you as if you
didn't realize that that's
one of the great actors
of all time. Because I was going
to say, what does better than that?
Was it all smoke and mirrors? Anybody
can get lucky with the deer hunter,
taxi driver, raging bull,
Goodfellas. Anybody can get
loved because see, you know,
yeah. Uh, main streets. Uh, what was the,
let's go back and forth
to see me to ever moves.
We was the one that he played ruper
Pumpkin, the comedian a comedy. Great.
Wasn't it phenomenal? I can't believe
I don't own that. That's like a sin.
I know as a comedian that I, I
don't, uh, I don't know that.
Let me ask you, let me ask you
a favorite actor of all time.
Oh Geez.
Comedy or a drama trauma.
They don't let a lot of convenience to,
even though our lives are so critically
the like acting compared to movie stars.
Uh, let's make sure you have
the mic up. They'd dump. Oh,
you proposed shit. Sorry. I would say, um,
maybe Pachino Ah,
let me be Chino because of a dog day
afternoon. But the narrows right there.
I mean those two guys, you're not
cause there were Italian, you know,
I mean like ned Beatty is a great app.
Made the greatest movies of
the last 40 years. Yeah, I
mean, do you know, you know,
uh, I was joking with somebody
who does yours before we go,
I always talk about this
greatest imdv page. Flawless is,
is John [inaudible],
John [inaudible] I MVP for eight.
He has five movies. All were
nominated for Best Pitch Godfather.
Then he was in the conversation all
day, afternoons, Godfather to dog day,
afternoon, and then the deer hunter.
Wow. He doesn't have one. Uh, you know,
boat trip we had, doesn't
have one now. Dude. Money.
Like what went bad news bears part
three. Like what was it? That room,
those are rang Tang movies.
Clint Eastwood was the one,
he didn't show up in any of those things.
I fucked him.
That's a really sweet short resume,
Huh? Five those five movies.
I took a train with him just
by coincidence from really
from New York to Boston.
Him and his girlfriend were sitting
next to me and we talked the whole time.
Meryl Streep? No, I don't
think so. He's beside his
girlfriend. But towards the end,
yeah. I didn't know her.
I didn't know who was
sound good. He was, he was giving her
tips and I watched this thing. Uh,
uh, what, what's, what's
the famous phrase? I knew it
was you. You broke my heart.
Is that the other two?
I knew it was you in the boat.
So there's a documentary
that was on HBO called.
I knew it was you and it was about John
Because Alan and like, and it dude,
it's just, it's Deniro, OPA,
Chino, Meryl Streep, all this just,
he was so great and dog day, afternoon,
the way he played that psychotic guy, the,
uh, we remember, he didn't
even know what Montana was,
thought it was a country or something.
Just that innocent stupidity psycho. Yeah.
Never been out of Brooklyn away,
right. The whole way that they did.
The whole thing is your favorite.
Oh, I have the hackiest I like,
I like going to Laurence Olivier.
Those guys are great too, you know. All
right, well I'll, I'll, I'll give you the,
the, when I was young I was, I liked, uh,
leave me out of this. I
like, I, I was Lee Marvin,
Charles Bronson,
Charles Bronson.
I just watched one of his old movies
called the big house in 1955 years.
Small partner. And I'm telling
you as far as like physiques,
he's the original like fucking marketing.
He was dude,
he was fucking shredded before people
knew how to do p nine dx as he used to
work in mines and Poland.
Like back then,
like what I love about the forties and
50s and even into the sixties like,
like being in shape just meant you
weren't fat. You know what I mean?
Like when those guys like
let's you were Hercules
or one of those guys,
but even some of them back in the
back way earlier that didn't have the
muscularity.
Yeah.
Like you watch like Ben Hur and they're
all just like Weissmuller all suck in
their guts in,
they always had like some sort of like,
it looked like have some sort of wrestling
championship belt that they would put
Lomas like a,
a cumber bun that they would always have
over their gut and they would just sort
of have their sort of, uh, sort of
packs. Right. You know what I mean?
It was just like they just
showed up with what they had.
Christopher Christopher Reeves, who was
the guy who played superman. Christopher,
he's now the other, the older superman
and television. He wasn't in show his, no.
Who is it? Shape it all? He Leonardo,
I played Batman wasn't in shape
that a white utility belt,
but his brother was Hercules' oh,
Steve Reeves and his name was Reeves too,
even though, but, and he, he was
really in shape. Excuse me. Bless you.
It is one of those guys that really look
like a look like Hercules and they both
thought they both did. Superman dry
died tragically then that weird.
I remember I used to do a bit on
Christopher Reeves and it was, it was,
it was after, you know, he got paralyzed,
which might seem insensitive
but I was tight. But it was no,
I was actually talking
about what a pussy I was.
People had like those horrific
fucking injuries like that.
And then they always go, I, you
know, I consider it a blessing.
I'm just going to every day I'm
alive and Blah Blah Blah and like,
and then they always go like,
well God,
pick them because he knew that
he could handle this challenge.
Might bit was don't have a fucking pick
me cause I'll be in that wheelchair.
Kill me fucking kill me.
Just being in the head and kill me.
And I was saying how I would steer the,
the fucking wheelchair.
I'd zone myself down the stairs.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
I can handle.
The only thing I can handle is somebody's
Wa flipping me over it and fucking a
wipe my ass and I would just be going,
I would just have to be joking around.
I shouldn't be saying this.
There's a few things I'd never make fun
of us when I was younger. I never make,
I don't make fun of handicapped. I
don't like. I actually know some things.
I don't make fun.
I don't make them a special needs kids.
There's just shit I don't do.
Ooh,
I just make fun of like
adult retarded kids.
We started people rather I, once they
get to a certain age, you can make fun.
You want to hear one story that I tell
that that I only usually tell offstage.
I was at a, I was in a red sox
game fan way plaque, right?
And I'm sitting in the bleachers and
there was this family of like it was a
father with three sons.
Two of them were just regular people
and the other one was special needs,
but he was a monster.
He was like fucking six,
two and we were sitting out in center
field and we will almost behind the
bullpen. And so, you know the
weird configurations of Fenway,
it's like our row went to a wall and
then the wall went up and then there was
like left field, right field. It's
sort of like Centerfield I guess. Yeah,
it center,
right.
And then there's the center field
bleachers where the garage doors.
So the Keto at the mental problems was
like up against the wall or whatever.
And he was,
I don't know what his deal was.
He was getting worked up and his dad was
telling him to calm down and he's like,
fuck yeah, he's like Carson. And
he was like retarded or whatever.
And then his dad find goes, come on, calm
down. I think when the crowd was like,
oh Nah,
he was getting like amped up.
And then the kid got to
fucking amped up dance.
They come on and sit down and he
was like, no, I'm not shutting down.
His Dad wound up and as hard as he
could slug this kid in the chest. Well,
but the dad was like 65 and this kid was
like 28 and he was a monster and he hit
him in the chest and the
kids, fuck you, dude.
I was one of those things. Look
your Daddy, no one wanted the lab,
but it was fucking dude. He was like
right out of it. Like, I don't know,
we don't have a fucking
like over the top comedy.
And then you will also terrify
because you're like, yeah,
get that dude settle down because
he's big enough to kill all of us. Ah,
what am I doing?
I'm talking about people with wheelchairs
is all the shit I don't talk. Yeah.
Well, I got a Charles Bronson story that
I was doing a roast for Mickey Rooney,
right. And I'm there with
Martin Landau, George Segal, me,
Charles Bronson.
This is the half of the day,
if someone that is Christ
and Charles Bronson, I go,
I just turned to him and he was
very quiet, you know, and I said,
am I gotta tell you it's really
cool to meet you? And he goes,
we're not even like inflecting
any, make any emotion. He goes,
pitch been at Napkin and I go,
yeah, how fucking cool is that?
Branson, he's so rude. I love it. Right?
So I go up on stage and I'm like roast
and not only Mickey Rooney but like other
people and the day is, and I tell
the story about Bronson, I go,
how cool that he's like,
you know, this is Charles,
this guy is death wish guy and he's so
cold that he doesn't even accept a count.
Me just ask me for it and the Napkin
and then I come and I sit down and goes,
hey man, I'm sorry I can't hear
out of this year. I got shit.
I wanted you to be
mean. You know dude, I loved all those
guys. And I was wondering the other day,
like I was talking to somebody going like,
why did it the stars back then the Lee
Marvin Sapp Bronson's and all them.
Why did they seem through, those guys were
like 130 140 pounds. But you just had,
they had that vibe. Like I was like,
I would never fuck with that guy.
And then you look at the stars today,
you look at Brad Pitt had, you know,
fuck him or whatever the guy is like
six, two, six, three shredded, right?
It's the highlights in his hair. I
don't know what it is, but fucking,
I finally was reading
something about Lee Marvin Lee.
Marvin was fought in world
war two and like his entire,
he was like one of two people who survived
as entire platoon eat to got a purple
heart and all that. And it's like, no
wonder we seem like such a fucking bad ass
was remember him in the Wild
One? Marlon Brando, you should.
Well, I think the big red one
was Lee Marvin, the wild one.
Was that the one with the motorcycle one?
I saw that.
But you know what's the worst,
the cringeworthy movement moment in that
movie is when they start singing those
two actors and you can clearly see
that there. Actress playing tough guys,
they start singing like some sort of
do up at the end of the bar and they're
supposed to be shocking. The
bartender, dude. It's such a Douche
chills moment where I remember
that that was in why one?
As long as you've got the Harley
and they come into town. Yeah.
The one where it goes, that's calm
ball style. Marlon Brando had that one.
Do you know what the, you know when you
play the a, the Wilbur theater and uh,
yeah, in Boston, that Green Room
Brando live there. Oh really? Yeah.
I had heard that he was tell the story
like he, when he was a broke actor,
he was doing the doing theater and that
was like some sort of dressing room.
He was so broke. He actually stayed. Yeah.
I'm a, I'm afraid of that place
when there's people in there,
I can't imagine going to bed
because the place is haunted.
Oh, you think it is. Do you believe
in ghosts? Oh yeah. Fuck yeah.
I don't believe in them. Although
when I come down here, I, I kind of,
I heard one time I heard one so clearly.
Then here's a, I'm in my Bo.
No, a cough just kept coughing.
It was, oh, don't, I don't get any sort
of laugh on that or the Gospel. Clearly
he had broadcasters speech,
sorry.
No, no. I hear, I'm in bed.
I had a studio apartment.
I just moved out from my wife
and I hear a cough. I go,
Oh God, you know, guys, got a club. I
go, guys, you got a club? Who's in here?
It's only a studio.
So I go and I look and I walk through a
field of energy that my hair stood up in
the back. I got the chills, but
like a chilling feeling. And I go,
Oh shit, this is, it
was during the day too.
So I get down to the office and I tell
now, when you walk through
that energy, the person like,
like take over your body
and you started making like
pottery. I started, uh,
I started moonwalking around
the apartment. Uh, but anyway,
I said to the department manager,
so this is weird. She goes, oh,
that's the ghost with the smoking cough,
right?
That there was a regular ghosts there.
That is a stand.
So what the fuck is with that stupid show?
Ghost hunters, they can't find a
ghost. So save that Goddamn life.
That show is the funniest fucking show on
you.
Don't they find like an energy and then
they always know the name of the ghost
and they're like,
I'm here forever. I
don't understand. I uh,
I don't know about that shit. I don't
know that. I don't believe in God.
Um,
I believe that there's something beyond
all the time
since we have, there's, I believe
in all that stuff that's beyond us,
but we don't know what it is.
And religion is a guest and,
uh,
it just doesn't,
it just doesn't do it for me.
It just doesn't,
that whole fucking ain't got
to have faith. It's like, no,
you don't have the fucking answers.
To me, religion is science. Okay.
Science gives me fucking answers. And if
they don't have answers, they go, well,
we got to work on it. And then they
gradually figure out more shit. But then,
then there's the spiritual side where
you do something good, you feel good,
you do something bad, you
feel bad. And uh, yeah.
And like she like a psychopath. Yeah.
Um, I believe in that. And that's that,
that feeling I feel is in everybody,
unless you're a psychopath.
And I feel that religion exploit's
that and they turned it into this,
they turn it into a science. They turned
it into this formula and this this too.
Yeah.
And then they turn it into this punishment
thing and then there's this fucking
guy who's mad at me
cause I got a lap dance.
And it's like when you really just start
reading about space and how fucking
gigantic the Goddamn universities
is, the fact that, you know,
you're staring at me, it's
like me looking at it, uh,
a fucking an Amoeba and getting upset
about what the fuck is doing with other
Amoebas.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
The fact that God would need to be
praised and sung to would seem like he's
insecure big time, but how
could it be God, you know?
But that's where I don't get,
you know. Yeah. And it's like,
if I'm a fuck up, it's like,
it's like you made me like, where is
your responsibility? That's like a fight.
If I build a car and it doesn't
go and I get mad at the car. Yeah.
You know what I mean? You fucking
this car, this car is evil.
It needs to be thrown into a pit of fire.
I think I look,
I think if you're a piece of shit you,
you,
oh actually I'm a philosophy.
Another philosophy in this,
if you're a piece of shit, you basically
get yours in life. You do. Unless you're,
the brilliance of a
sociopath is you don't,
calmer doesn't affect you, I don't
think. Unless you believe in it.
If you don't believe in it,
then you don't feel like you did
anything bad and you just don't attract
anything bad to you. But if you
actually feel guilty, you bring it to,
cause there's guys,
I'm not going to name guys because I've,
I've seen guys in this
fucking business just do like,
you know people who they
just such a piece of shit.
It gets to the point where you're not
even Maddie Collins. It's like funny.
I Dunno Bobby like that, but like
it's, it becomes like funny. You know,
you don't get mad. They just
like what? Like, yeah, well
I don't want to name names.
I remember there was a guy,
this dude, this dude I do,
he borrowed somebody's workout
bench and he said, yeah,
I'll give it back to you in a week.
And He,
and he's the dude came back in a
week and he sold it. He sold it for,
I forget what,
but like some drugs or something.
And what I loved about it was just
that in the moment of it of like,
yeah, eventually in six days this
guy is going to come back and I says,
but for these next six days, I don't have
to deal with that guy in that moment.
I want drugs so fuck you.
So like that's that type of shit that,
that's such a dirt bag move. But that,
that thing, like if he had done it to me,
I would be mad. But the joy I would
get out of retelling the story,
don't you fucking believe
this kind of were laughing.
Like the joy that I would
get out of it. Like, yeah,
I could only get like a can only
get so mad at him. Um, well,
when you are speaking to that like,
cool. Yeah, we, I never named names.
I try not to name names and like
the podcast or something like that,
but I guess it's, there's always a,
there's always people that, you know,
not that I'm coastline and on whoever the
hell you just said that. Cause I don't,
I don't know the guy like that. I
Dunno. We're only an hour in done.
How easy with this our flow. Seamless with
you, Bill. Seamless. Terrific. Listen,
you know,
one of the best comedians around may
say that without the risk of the best,
it's turning into the Sami
Moylan show. Well, Tom,
I learned from stealing from you. I
stole all my stuff from you. I just,
I just turned it into the iron better man.
Can I steal a bag? Can I steal a
bag? Now that it's getting tighter,
let me just, just give me
another six months with it. Hey,
you know what I learned today?
Uh,
you cannot get a breakfast burrito on
Easter Sunday at any of these Mexican taco
stands. Speaking of Jesus,
they are Mexicans are,
are down with hey Seuss.
I went to three different places
to get a breakfast burrito.
And when I get a breakfast Burrito,
I don't want it made by white people who
looked over some Mexican guy's shoulder.
I want to, I want the real
fucking deal. Well, why don't you,
why don't you go to two?
Don't you think it's time to give up?
I thought it was a flu fact that he
went to three is kind of sad. No,
I went to the first one. People think
of you as a celebrity. He's done.
It's kind of sad seeing you driving
around Hollywood and a pres. Nope,
no burritos.
It's Easter bread.
It's Easter a man.
And one of them just had a big
picture of Jesus in the window.
I don't know if it's there every
time. Old Jay Star. Uh, hey dom,
do you play video games?
I do, Bill. Oh yeah.
Well what do you want to asteroids
PAC man. You old school like me,
I love to asteroids.
He hit hyperspace Ms Pac man pac man.
I got addicted to that so badly that I
would see it in my sleep or when I closed
my eyes. Let's see like
the last one, you know,
that's when you know you love video games.
I used to play uh,
some sort of sniper game and I remember
one day I played it like eight hours a
day and then I walked out on the street
and they had this thing like when you
get somebody in the scope,
like the scope would just fit
right over there that cross the X.
And I was walking down the street and
I was just looking at people cross the
street and I was seeing that x on
their head could blow them away.
It was awesome.
All right,
game fly.com a dom Arrera that this
is the best way to rent video games.
The second game, fly.com came fly.com
like, like basketball's a game.
And could you please zip up your
fly now it's, Oh, if it was,
I wouldn't tell you though.
I think you're adorable. Uh,
the best way to rent video games
are over 8,000, uh, console games.
There's no late fees.
You can cancel anytime that
introducing unlimited PC play.
Uh, look, if you don't have a PC,
they'll just deliver the games to you.
You get a 15 day free trial, dom,
8,000 games at your fingertips.
Use up all your vacation time, sit there
like Howard Hughes growing your nails,
your hair,
ordering pizzas,
play every game you ever wanted
to play for free for 15 days.
And then you can call them up
after 15 days and be like, yeah,
you know what I got to
get on with my life.
Or you can accept the how awesome this is
and you can keep going to and using it.
This is what, this is what
I would do if I, if, uh,
if I had the time to get
back into video games,
which I would love to do because I haven't
played them in five years or users.
Oh Dude,
I played the grand theft auto three.
It just took over my life and then I,
I loved it so much.
I played it for another year after where
I would just use the cheats and I would
go on a rampage and I would,
and I didn't like when the army showed up.
I like those secret service cars that
they would show up and kind of look like
the caprice classics.
But they will like hooked up.
I used to try to see how long it,
I dunno,
they would start to shift to think of it.
Ah, what about this? A little obsessive.
A little bit, a little bit, a little
bit of a little bit of obsessiveness.
Wait a minute,
I ain't got to type this back.
Did you ever do captain
Brian's and Marco Island?
Captain Brian's in Marco
Island? No, I did. I got to
finish this though. Go to game.
fly.com/bur bur are to
activate this special offer.
Look at me hooking you guys up.
You listen to this damn thing. You,
you can support the troops,
you can have the post office in your
own apartment and now you can have 8,000
video games at your fingertips. And on
top of that, I give you an hour of dom.
I rarer we, we barely scratched
the surface. That's right.
So what do you say a captain
Morgan's kept him. Brian,
it's in Marco Island and of the,
you're over there.
I'm there in a couple of weeks too.
By all means hype. Everything you got.
We're an hour and six in.
You know we're going to do dumb.
We're going to leave them wanting more.
That old show business.
Think Lennox city June 30th Tropicana
I and I'm telling you right now,
I'm no bullshit and I'm not just saying
it because he's sitting here staring at
me like, please compliment
me. So needy, needy, dumb,
dumb dog. Look on his face.
Dom. Irrera always funny.
Always funny.
Straight on through.
I've never seen you in
front of any fucking crowd,
any situation where you're not hilarious.
No bullshit,
no hacky lines.
Goes on stage,
assesses the crowd and you one of the
funniest fucking ball breakers. And Man,
I love you Dada. Love you too. It's
great. Great to have you on here.
[inaudible] this is the Monday
morning podcasts. Go fuck yourselves.
Don't take any shit. Hope you guys. I had
a good time. Listen to this and not Tom.
Thank you so much for honoring me by
coming by pleasure and I hope you enjoyed
the wine that you brought that gave you,
I think I'll go buy another
bottle and bring him back here.
You did everything because
I drag some of it. You did.
Everything would bring the glasses I owe
you, man. All right, brother. All right,
thanks. All right. See you.